I feel like it's all gonna be fanciest I
expect British snacks to all have sort
of like charming names as far as I know
there's bunch of sausages probably gonna
be like some preserved fish and chips
chocolate digestives chocolate-covered
wheat biscuits the name is the least
appealing thing I have heard it seems
like something that you would take when
you were sick like oh you have an upset
stomach here have this digestive biscuit
it's just a good cookie
is it digestive because it's good and
you'll eat it pork scratchings made from
the rinds or skin of the pig oh my god
that's that's very fragrant ours oh my
god that I kept the fat on there it says
although every care has been taken to
remove bones some may remain there's
bones y'all probably think they're so
gross though so Goods twiglets a wheat
based savory snack flavored using yeast
extract they kind of smell like old soy
sauce the snacks pretty confusing
because it's like like what is it they
are like rotten Cheetos or like burnt
sausage ends sweet you know this is kind
of good it kind of tastes like when you
burn toast and then you rolled it in
spicy cheeto dust monstermunch this
flavor is pickled onion and it's a baked
corn snack I know as a kid you were
supposed to do this I'm sure this is
like what you do with these and then you
like alright oh it was kinda sour it has
so much onion flavor that was like
making my mouth water a lot oh it's
awful by the end
Wow oh it's like everything that's wrong
with a Funyun with pickle juice on it
yeah you won't want to kiss people after
this they look like Funyuns but they
taste like a pickle that was left inside
somebody's gym sock Marmite a dark brown
salty paste made from yeast extract
what whoa hello it's a sour and salty at
the same time like you you gave me a
piece of salt and dipped in and vinegar
and made me lick it one brave soul
wanted to try mom might straight from
the jaw I'm so strong I know if I ever
go to England I'll stay away from the
snacks and go straight to the fish and
chips
I'm kind of disappointed that I didn't
get to have like some crumpets or some
like what Americans think English people
are eating all over town I feel like I
could get used to the Marmite in this
weird way a lot of these things were
like too flavorful and this like
vinegary salty spectrum the only thing
that wasn't salty was the digestive
cookie which maybe that is to help you
digest all that salt